Todd thanks for joining us what did you
make of Collinsworth with deshaun Watson
going for to Jacksonville it's
interesting you know I I don't expect it
to happen but I also I'm not going to be
overly surprised by much when it comes
to these quarterbacks I I don't it's
been about 15 years of doing this and I
don't know that I've ever been this
close to the actual draft and had less
of a feel of where the quarterbacks in
the first round are gonna go I mean I
here with Pat mahomes from Texas Tech I
grade him out of the second round
quarterback I know some guys in the
league have a second third round but
there are some teams that that clearly
from Intel that we're getting and
talking to guys that view him a lot
higher and people are saying he might
even go in the top 10 15 picks in the
draft and so deshaun Watson I've heard
that Chicago has a little bit of
interest that Jacksonville we're not
sure if they're gonna stick with bortles
but they have a little bit of interest
I've heard San Francisco like strabinsky
coming out of North Carolina but maybe
they don't they don't want to spend that
number two overall pick on him and then
you've got Cleveland sitting there 12
looking for a quarterback in the Jets at
six looking for a quarterback and it
just creates a lot of unknown because I
don't think any of these quarterbacks
truly belong in the top ten but we know
that position and how that just drives
up the value all right how does
Cleveland get this right take miles
Garrett the defensive end from Texas A&M
take him at one take the best player on
the board and then I would personally
try to get creative and package picks
I'm not a big fan of moving up I would
much rather take some deals from teams
that are panicked and trying to move up
for one player and take advantage of
that and get multiple picks especially
in this draft where you have really good
second third fourth round value but when
you need a quarterback it's a different
deal I think if they if there's one that
they really like even though the you
don't want to be taking one in the top
ten if you've already gotten Miles
Garrett at one I would package some of
the picks that they have and they've got
a punch they take a 112
3352 and 65
all I would try to package a couple of
those pics and go up ahead of maybe the
Jets Tennessee is shown with Robinson
their general manager the willingness to
move back maybe they do it again this
year and go up there and go get trip
iski if that's your guy Watson if that's
your guy
whoever it is I would go and take
another crack at it because I don't
think that they have the starting
quarterback of the future Cleveland
Browns already on their roster right now
what is your one big question of
Mitchell true Biscay inexperience is
probably the biggest thing because just
the 13 starts which we've heard a
million times but it's real you know I
I'm sick of saying it I'm sick of saying
he only has 13 starts but you see it in
his play some of a little bit of the
inconsistency not seeing the entire
field Stanford game the two
interceptions he threw he just didn't
see backside coverage or a safety
working over the top and and those are
things with more game experience that
he'll start to see the game will the
cliche slow down and he'll see more of
the field and understand most
importantly what defenses are trying to
do to him before they actually do it but
I'll be honest - I his tape I he grew on
me I thought his tape of all these
quarterbacks was the best and most
consistent from this past year he is
really he's got a great feel inside the
pocket really good poised he's got a
quick release gets the ball out he can
throw with anticipation and hit spots
and he's really very mobile I mean he
can buy a lot of extra time too so I
think he's the complete package
physically it's just the lack of
experience and then what is he as a
leader he seems that very kind of dry
and you know a good approach worked hard
and does all the right things but does
he have that presence to him and I'm not
saying he doesn't but I just a lot of
people I talked to who have been around
him like him but I just you know did you
see Jameis Winston in the room and yes
he has his issues but everyone flocks to
him and he's a great and just natural
leader and there are a lot of guys like
that with true Biscay I think it's a
little bit of an unknown how do you know
you're not being lied to
I have three people in the way
that I that I know for sure not lying to
me everybody else is lying way shape or
form and I've just I've become really
close friends and I've known only the
three guys for a long time and so I
trust them and I'll ask sometimes
question all the time I won't even
bother most stuff they know that they
don't want to talk to me bucks it's just
it I don't want to put them in a spot
but if I ask him something and every
once in a while said you know what I
can't go there
but everything else they tell me is true
and so you learn to rely on that yeah
other people for the most part talk in
generalities or just talking players and
I know that they're being honest with
their assessment but they're very rarely
hey who are you taking with that pick
you know those questions to me are just
they don't make sense and once you get
past the third pick is you alluded to
with the mock drafts one if there's one
trade and some moves around everything
can completely change you know it's a
completely different picture than what
you expected when you're on the board
let's say at number five or six overall
so who they say they're going to take
and who's available at that point are
two very different situations
he's Todd McShea NFL draft analyst
tonight SportsCenter special milk hyper
draft expert and Todd mock drafted 7:00
Eastern
with your host Trey Wingo Trey of course
hosting the draft this year instead of
Chris Berman but you start to look at
guys when they move up and I always view
it as the media puts players in a place
and then the scouts come back and hit
the reset button and then we go over
guys moving up guys moving down when in
reality they're not moving up or down as
much as the scouts are just dis paying
attention to it we're Christian
Hackenberg man he's the he's gonna be
the number one big and then all of a
sudden you're like well maybe not how do
we get to this point where we look at
these mock drafts and then you get to a
point where you go okay this I feel like
is a true mock draft as opposed to one
that you may have put out last year or
six months ago well I just finished fine
the last of 350 evaluations last week I
mean I'm talking four days ago and I
didn't you know in the preseason we do
about a hundred so players and evaluate
them on tape and try to get a baseline
for their evaluation but
there are also 250 players or we're
going to wind up evaluating we haven't
even looked at we don't start till
December so I start watching tape when
the college football season is over and
people are moving up and down because
I'm changed I'm going in and putting a
grade on them that is reflective of what
I'm evaluating and people are saying how
someone moving up or down when he's not
even playing football I just got to his
evaluation and it's a long process and
so as the process goes for me my you
know evaluation and player grades wind
up changing based on one I wind up doing
that individual player in that position
and so and then you go through the
process of collecting information
usually in April early April I start
with the character and durability that
just didn't know about it and then
you've got the in the middle of the
month I could combine recheck for the
injuries and durability and so there's a
lot of information that floods in in the
final few weeks with the character and
durability that has nothing to do with
who they are as football players I mean
there are 10 guys right now in my top 20
I don't know where they're gonna wind up
falling just because there's some
off-the-field issues or some durability
it's I think Jonathan Allen from Alabama
is one of the three best players in this
entire draft but there are some teams
that are really concerned about his
shoulders yeah and so where does he wind
up falling Dalvin cook is arguably the
best back in this class if you're just
basing it off of tape coming out of
Florida State but there's serious
character concerns in terms of who he
surrounds himself with and what's going
to happen when you give shame free time
and money than he's ever had before and
you worry about that and teams are
worried about that and every team I've
been talking to recently says you know
what Allen cooks going to slip a little
bit and could wind up being the third or
fourth running back taken when he should
be probably a top 15 pick if Jared Goff
was in this draft where would he go he
would be based off the evaluation like
coming in I would guess that he would be
in my opinion I had him as the second
best quarterback last year and I would
have him right there with I would have
him ahead of triskin you in the second
quarter back to it if once was in this
class as well it's not then he probably
based off my evaluation
would be from a year ago would be the
first quarterback taken just ahead of
triskin what about running backs I know
McCaffrey this is one of those that hey
he might be he might slip into the end
of the first round and now all of a
sudden he's now 15 or maybe even higher
than that so what is it that McCaffrey
is offering here that he suddenly was at
the end of the first round now he could
be in the mid first round I think there
a couple things I think first of all as
the process has gone on and through
workouts and evaluating his tape and the
realization he's he's a guy that yes
you're gonna give ten or so carries to a
game but you also can legitimately put
him in in the slot I think he's one of
the two or three best slot receivers in
this class so now that's an added
element I think as coaches got more and
more involved in the scouting process
they stopped looking at it like some of
the scouts said you know who cares if
we're we don't want to give them more
than ten carries a game we can put them
out it in the slot receiver spot not
worry about him in pass protection which
is probably his biggest weakness as a
football player when we're going to
throw the ball we're going to have them
out in the slot we're going to create
mismatches like New England has done for
years with their you know smaller
receivers and running backs hybrid guys
and take advantage room that way and if
we want to do some in the return game we
can - the other part is the combine
workout you want to see numbers that are
as good as what you see on tape and they
were even better they were exceptional
so trying to check that box and [ __ ]
some eyes and and I think thirdly and
really importantly at this point of the
process the clean guys guys with no off
the field issues wind up moving up
because there's a general manager
sitting there say who's the deal guy I'm
going to take well I'm not gonna lose my
job because he's going to be a bustin
out of the league and we blew it on that
pick and I think McCaffrey in terms of
you sleeping at night knowing that you
got a player that's going to contribute
loves the game and it's going to show up
with an unbelievable work ethic and
passion for the game he's one of the
five players in this draft that you're
just you have no concern about what if I
gave you the first-round quarterbacks
taken and I get everybody else and then
five years from now we
look back to say who made the smarter
bet on who was gonna be a better
quarterback would you take the
quarterbacks that are going in the first
round or all the other quarterbacks who
will be drafted I'd take the field I'd
rather take Josh Dobbs if I could get
him coming out of Tennessee in the third
round and not have any pressure first
time in his life this guy's a genius and
the first time in his life he's actually
gonna be able to focus fully on football
and sit him down for a year so keep
working with them and and also be able
to use my first two picks on other guys
that will help them give you know
improve our supporting cast and take a
chance on Dobbs and I would use the top
ten pick on to this key or deshaun
Watson or certainly Pat mahomes who I
think is unbelievably talented but would
be a a stripped down and build back up
type of project before I let you go if
you and Mel Kiper got into a fistfight
on the air how would it play out please
Dan come on that's insulting oh boy
breaking news Mel Piper's lost his step
according to Todd McShea you may be in
his head pumpkin pumpkin pie for
breakfast every day his lunch as a milky
way I mean I told him yesterday yeah I
can't believe he's still alive yeah but
he might have pumpkin pie for breakfast
and a candy bar for lunch but he's
having you for dinner
[Laughter]
all right well play nice next week okay
well you will Thank You bud Thank You
Todd the Dan Patrick show weekday
mornings on audience
you